you're all sisters well tell me about
you guys and then i'll wrap up that what
do you guys do
oh can we just not go there
i have a talking professor that's fine
hannah emery and claire dog named
professor but wait so why don't you want
to go
i mean it's just like you know just
useful pin me as a certain person
not one okay fine i'm an e-commerce
consultant oh yeah okay no that's fine
i don't know what that means well i go
to school in arkansas i like fanny packs
i'll stand further away and mask down
okay
so we're good okay hannah and marie clay
you've already had it
my gosh let's do this
three sisters with the blonde hair she's
already had the colvin name claire
and then we go to the side yes sure with
hannah and a nice pooch
professor like x from x-men i'm checking
see it there in the wheelchair
call it professor xavier i'm assuming
your dog's got the use of its legs
and what's going on in emery's head
she's like
what's the purpose to be on this earth
i'm consulting
in e-commerce and helping people when
they got their little business
and putting other emails impress
everything
buying each that they saw and then we
got you in
arkansas in fayetteville yeah i don't
know a lot
once a time ago i visit little rock it
was real [ __ ]
what a horrible city if you're living
there now your city is shitty i don't
like it
but that's okay i missed there we did a
trio with the sisters you like fanny
packs
and let me say my mind's on that in my
country we don't call it call a bum bag
that's
a true fact because a fanny is your bum
and now
more words from the four give more call
it ass a
double less shake it like you're
twerking i like checking out the asses
go berserking
a strip club i make the thing clap like
the mother lode yeah
and then the rap what did you say corgi
it's kind of odd
they hear the accent say that's a
british dog
owned by the queen keep it in her home
buckingham palace they're always
[ __ ] on the throne
bowing down with the brown and the white
fur i need more words
give it right there throw it in yeah you
said it like you asked
water from the man with a nice mustache
it's real nice
yeah i might befriend you in the past
mustachement you're a sex offender but
that's okay
flow like waters off a duck's back
that's the water the h2o i knock back
what we got one more here we go stand on
one leg when i rap like flamingo
like a pink thing eating all the krill
see them in the zoo turn gray when
they're ill that's a true fact
need to get the color in the feather
there we go we drop a wrap from a
british fella i hope you enjoyed it
bringing you all together with the
rhymes that we did that are clever
that's
it
[Applause]
i hope you're enjoying the video make
sure you hit that like button and i will
release another episode of me rapping in
crested butte
a cutting kid thumb up on the table side
okay so a kid cutting his thumb off in a
wood shop and traumatic family
counselling
okay it's going to be a nice and easy
one i'm going to drop feet
explicit just really horrible make this
explicit
i better make it good i'm slipping on
the table saw and then i'm gushing blood
like a geyser
like old faithful in yellowstone i gotta
call the parents i gotta get him home
he's yelling out like please sir i used
to have a thumb right there see
there but now there's nothing all the
pain it lingers in the shop you the wood
tools now four fingers
what's he gonna do no hitchhiking he's
got no thumb
all the cars ride by him they're like
[ __ ] the guy i saw him before
leave him on the hard shoulder and the
saw slice right through
leave him on his own bleeding out upon
the floor exmiting to pull the bone and
the flesh and the skin
i don't want to make you fame but let me
say it's my favorite
place i'm no slouch when i'm there on
the therapist couch
marriage counseling yeah you know gotta
allow got the lady with the ring and she
throws it on the floor and says i caught
my husband with the neighborhood [ __ ]
no more i'm calling a divorce the
husband's like no i deny it of course
i'm not saying this is what happens
every session but
distinct way back they were popping the
question but now
they're totally kind of broke down cause
he's gone around every hole in town is
like no
please i vouch for him you try and fix
this [ __ ] with the counseling
and what do you offer what do you say
maybe you could dress up and do some
role play that's actually a quick fix
everybody knows there we go
counseling and the wood shop bro
[Applause]
a [ __ ] zoo okay cool so covered
quarantine
bikes crested butte and a shih tzu this
is a freestyle
like i said made up on the spot i love
your louis vuitton um
sneakers by the way are they real are
you very wealthy
they're oh they're vans that okay great
i like it nice
not real lv it's a screen print on the
vans when you're in quarantine
you're like oh [ __ ] i wish that i did
all of the live events before
kovid 19 came up from the east locked
down
two weeks at least if you've been in
contact with infected people gotta stay
inside
yeah never be a c4 technically it's
gonna spike again
when you're on the mountain with your
friends you wanna have fun
how you even gonna do it no wheels on
the bike yeah how you pursue it just one
like a unicycle it's vital
hands in the air when you walk past the
side oh yeah
burned orange with the beanie no gold no
mask on don't be
these that's okay bike with the seat
when you got the shock absorbers you
need those hitting other things and i
want to see they're just
checking his phone like justin bieber i
like that
looking so smooth diamonds in the air
he's a crested beaut
dude do you live here maybe just a
tourist a great sound in the shadow of a
mountain i adore this look at the
crepuscular rays i need a little dog
from the shelter to save
walking in there i pick you like a
pokemon it's a cute [ __ ] zoo
pick it up it's a dog that's small
neuter the dog so we ain't got no balls
not a [ __ ] it's a man so we can't have
the puppy i'm loving the [ __ ] zoo yeah i
had a lucky
if you only got a lion and a rhino
that's a [ __ ] zoo
get the joke bro like that anyway we
flow for you guys yeah three guys and
one goal
it's gonna say bro but it don't make
sense i like that your hands in your
pocket so tense that you're feeling
slightly underwhelmed but there you go
that's the rap that i tell there you go
a cute kitten and a bus stop okay i'm
gonna drop a little beat for you guys
this is a freestyle all made up about
those things so uh
let's do it
i'm feeling in love i'm feeling smitten
got a cute little cat like i'm picking
the kitten it's got the whiskers
i risk there i survive like a cat you
know i've got
nine lives if you cough on me i still
pull right through
i need a bit of cream what does this do
preparation h
it helps me soothe i apply it to my
backside reading the tube it's not
lube it's like a numbing thing like an
ointment
put it on the finger the ring remove it
if you're at the doctor and follow this
he says chris bend over proctologist is
the speciality that i study
i'm not a doctor i'm just a busy body
who likes to walk around and insert my
phalanges
most obvious thing from the man please a
bus stop
it says it on the wall get imagination
the brain too small
but that's okay that's the thing on
offer are you here at the stop off the
tree the doctor
visit over there hard to avoid check the
prostate
check the hemorrhoids and here's my
advice from me to you
if you don't want hemorrhoids don't
spend too long on the loo there you go
thank you for watching guys make sure
you like comment subscribe
and i will see you next time for another
episode of me rapping in crested butte